[Music]
breaking news this Monday Britain's
Prime Minister is in intensive care the
latest on Boris Johnson's condition and
who is running that country now new
advice from Canada's public health
officer wearing a non-medical mass is an
additional measure what is the most
effective and simple homemade mask as
Canada and the u.s. keep fighting over
supplies for frontline workers and that
of course is a two-way street and
personal protection equipment is running
low I don't sleep at night thousands
applied for the emergency benefit what
about those who don't qualify and the
pressure mounts to ramp up testing in
Canada
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we have lots of Canadian news to get to
tonight and we will in just a moment but
we begin with breaking news from London
the British prime minister Boris Johnson
is in intensive care because his
coronavirus symptoms have worsened he's
the first world leader we know up to
become so seriously ill Johnson tested
positive 11 days ago he kept working
from number 10 Downing Street where he
was in self isolation now he's in much
worse shape his officials say he remains
conscious and has been moved to the ICU
in case he needs to be put on a
ventilator crystal command Singh has
more on the fight of Boris Johnson's
life the British prime minister has been
moved into intensive care a spokesperson
for the government says the move will
allow him to be put on a ventilator
should he require it earlier Monday
Boris Johnson updated his medical status
on social media writing in part I went
to hospital for some routine tests as
I'm still experiencing coronavirus
symptoms I'm in good spirits and keeping
up with my team we last saw him Thursday
out his door taking part in the clap for
care workers his condition has clearly
deteriorated
we know he has been struggling with
persistent cough and fever however when
he was admitted to hospital Sunday it
was said to be non urgent he shared the
news of his original diagnosis on social
media March 27th at that point he said
he was experiencing mild symptoms his
pregnant fiancee also reported symptoms
and was in self-isolation
separate from the PM Kerry Simmons last
updated her status saying she was on the
mend Johnson has asked that his
unofficial second-in-command
Dominic Robb be deputized to stand in
for him Johnson is 55 years old we know
people infected with the virus can
deteriorate quickly the unit he is now
on can provide more surveillance and
stepped-up medical intervention if it's
required the fact that Boris Johnson is
in intensive care tonight a shock for
many
people here in the UK considering
earlier in the day people were still
being told it's just a precaution not
surprisingly an outpouring of support on
social media people wishing him well and
of course for a speedy recovery Donna
all right crystal the man Singh in
London thanks there is news tonight
about medical grade masks President
Trump had ordered the company 3m to stop
importing masks it makes and overseas
factories he wanted them all made in
America and to stop shipping any to
Canada Canada pushed back and tonight
the company says it will import 166
million respirators over the next three
months to support health care workers in
the US and that plan will also enable 3m
to continue sending us produced
respirators to Canada and Latin America
where 3m is the primary source of supply
there is another fright brewing with the
u.s. after reports hundreds of thousands
of medical medical grade masks bound for
Ontario were held up at the US border
and of course is a two-way street both
countries benefit from this and both
countries would lose out if hurdles were
to be put in the way of that flow of
healthcare support between our two
countries and there is new advice today
about wearing homemade masks in public
even if you have no symptoms public
health officers in Canada now say they
may provide some protection from
infecting others but they are no
substitute for physical distancing Mike
Doral a on the developing story around
masks there is no more sought-after item
in the medical supply world right now
when a shipment of american-made n95
masks bound for Ontario was stopped at
the border on the weekend it set off a
political tug-of-war getting in across
the border right now is very difficult
right now and I understand there's two
separate orders of close to four million
masks to half a million have been
released the fight over mass hit its
crescendo last Friday when US President
Donald Trump invoked the defense
production Act preventing 3m from ex
to Canada and Latin America disappointed
in 3m they should be taking care of our
country on Monday Ontario's premier was
blunt frontline workers are running out
we're down to about a week supply and
it's not much better in Quebec Lisak mom
oh no I train my cattle rule where
they're down to under two weeks
supplying 3m says it is able to
manufacture about 100 million n95 masks
per month which would be a remarkable
number except for the unprecedented
global demand Deputy Prime Minister
Krishna Freeland called the marketplace
for masks the Wild West France and
Brazil are among countries complaining
about being dramatically outbid on
orders all of which has led to Canada's
chief public health officer to instruct
hospitals to hold on to use masks that
could be disinfected and now telling the
public homemade masks are better than no
masks at all wearing a non-medical mask
is an additional measure that we are
considering to protect others around you
we're so little inventory she says all
the medical grade masks are needed for
frontline workers microlight Global News
Toronto the reason we're being asked to
stay home if we can and stay physically
distant from others is to stop the
spread if this virus can't reach you it
can't infect you and you should assume
that everyone has it
but the outbreaks and the level of
testing varies depending on where you
live in this country tonight Eric
Sorenson looks at what the data reveals
at this stage kovat 19 has moved across
the country in stages the exposure and
incubation at first invisible then we
saw hard evidence illness started to
spread and now we are witnessing the
third phase the sobering statistics that
Canadians are dying in greater numbers
Ontario's premier somber in emphasizing
the dangerous time we've entered in here
in Ontario we have 1600 lives at stake
this month alone this is a matter of
life or death the impact of kovat 19 has
been seen most tragically in seniors and
extended care facilities across the
country we know that
it gets entered into a long-term care
facility we can have devastating results
Canada's first death from Kovan 19 was
recorded on March the 8th it took more
than three weeks to reach 100 deaths on
March the 31st but then just four more
days to pass 200 and it was approaching
300 just one day after that the sharp
rise in mortality will continue but for
how long and by how much it is a
critical month for this country because
it is more than numbers these are lives
two provinces are on the most worrisome
pads Ontario at a hundred and thirty two
deaths as of today Quebec now at 121
both also have a high percentage of
positive tests in Quebec 8.6% in Ontario
five point five a sign there may be more
undetected cases the average across the
other provinces and territories 2.2
percent positive tests but testing has
not been uniform across the country
Alberta has tested more than 14,000 per
1 million population followed by Quebec
and Saskatchewan Ontario has conducted
just over 5,000 fewer than half the
tests per capita than the top three
provinces
experts believe widespread testing can
save lives by tracking the spread of
kovat 19 those numbers are extremely
helpful in providing public health
support for different places but also at
the individual level is extremely
important to help guide individual
management and individual care overall
Canada has done more testing than many
countries we've done relatively more
testing than other places despite all of
our challenges we've done we've done
pretty well but more needs to be done as
Canada faces a statistical upturn in the
numbers that ultimately matter most our
mortality rate
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto
testing here in Canada has been ramping
up but it's not at the point where
everyone with symptoms is getting a test
Canada is spending millions of dollars
on new technology that will produce more
and faster testing but as abigail Beeman
reports it's not here yet
phone booth testing sites in South Korea
a doctor who set up a makeshift test
tent in Germany two countries faring
relatively well in this pandemic both
have high testing rates every single day
we are doing more tests than the day
before we recognize that large-scale
testing is a key element of flattening
the curve in Canada more than 330
thousand people have been tested but
there are countless people with symptoms
who have not with restrictions across
the country on who is eligible due to a
limited supply and priority for health
care workers and vulnerable communities
and the country's biggest province
Ontario with the most deaths still lags
behind you want the tests that you have
and whatever you have pity on
populations where you are going to make
a decision after you've actually got the
test results so if you're just staying
home anyways we're gonna be prioritizing
others Ottawa still won't say how many
test kits they've ordered just that
they're ordering more trying to focus on
domestic production in the face of a
global shortage such as their contract
with Spartan bioscience for quick test
kits we're gearing up now to be able to
produce millions of these tests per year
in Canada and now we are very soon going
to be getting health care approval and
starting to ship it out and Canada's
chief public health officer says they're
looking at sera logic testing in future
seeing if people carry the antibodies
were infected but recovered to look at
immunity either you're not sick or
you're immune either one would be a yes
and I think that's where we need to go
in order to make herself safe and
equally important as testing as people
try and figure out how to one day return
to a normal life contact tracing the
painstaking work of trying to figure out
everyone with whom an infected person
has come into contact and get in touch
with them to Ottawa is currently calling
for volunteers across the country to
help Donna
all right Abigail Beeman and Ottawa
thanks hundreds of thousands of
Canadians have already applied for the
federal emergency response benefit
within the first nine hours of the
online portal being open at least five
hundred and thirty-two thousand people
applied for the benefit
that's only a fraction of the number of
Canadians who have been laid off of
course or had their hours reduced
because of this pandemic the federal
government says an average of 1000
applications are being processed right
now every minute there are others of
course who don't meet these guidelines
the prime minister said today the
program will still be fine-tuned our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
joins me now Mercedes walk us through
who qualifies for the CRB and how much
they'll get so Donna with the website
opened today those born between January
and March can apply and they've actually
staggered who can apply each day based
on your birth month because there are so
many Canadians who are expected to flood
the system
let's walk folks at home through exactly
what makes you eligible and what the CRB
will do it will provide $2,000 a month
for up to four months you have to live
in Canada in order to qualify for it and
you must be at least 15 years old when
you apply you also have to have habited
an income over the past year of at least
$5,000 and have had no income for 14
straight days now in terms of who having
lost their job can get this well anyone
who has lost it as a result of kovat 19
or is not able to work because of the
pandemic that includes people who are
ill people who've been laid off those
who are at home looking after an ill
family member and Donna also those who
are at home looking after children now
that schools are not in session Mercedes
we know there'll be people who won't
meet these criteria who won't be
eligible for this what is Ottawa doing
for them so the Prime Minister says that
they know that there are holes in the
system and let's take a look at some of
the people who don't qualify right now
and this is people who are hoping to
qualify those who are working part-time
those who have any kind of income
whatsoever even a little bit counts you
can't have any to qualify for the C ERV
and on top of that summer students lots
of people about to graduate from
university looking for a job we spoke to
one woman who is a personal trainer she
is experienced between a five and seven
thousand dollar decrease in her personal
income a month but because she's still
training people a little bit from home
to try to make some money she's not
eligible for this benefit this is what
she had to say about the government's
program it was really frustrated because
I feel like as a small business owner
one of the things we can do and we do
well is that we are creative and we can
innovate and we can pivot and I feel
like I'm being penalized for doing that
Donna the government says that they know
that there are holes in the system and
they will be working to fix some of
those in coming days
they've already addressed one of them
which is people who will be seeing their
AI benefits and soon they'll be
transferred on to the CRB since they
can't go out and find a new job in this
environment Donna okay Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
well if you're applying for the Canada
Emergency Response benefit you can do so
on the federal government website canada
dot CA or you can call the phone number
is
close to 100 Canadians stuck on the
coral Princess cruise ship are a heading
home Foreign Affairs Minister Francois
Philippe champagne tweeted Canadians who
pass medical screening will be able to
return to Canada on a flight chartered
by Holland America when they arrive in
Canada they will be screened again and
then subject to mandatory 14 days
self-isolation two people on board the
coral princess have died from Cove in
1912 others tested positive that's
according to Princess Cruises health
officials in the United States say the
next two weeks are critical the number
of deaths in that country has now stored
past 10,000 public health officials have
warned this week will bring more death
and heartache right across America
Jackson prosto reports in this critical
time New York's hospitals are being
pushed to their breaking point
old people young people people are dying
from this it is lethal 80% of the
patients at this Brooklyn Hospital are
being treated for kovat 19 nurses wear
garbage bags and clean their clothes
with sanitizing wipes doctors wear ski
goggles we're seeing a lot of younger
healthier patients and they're coming in
in a very critical state with hundreds
of deaths every single day funeral homes
and morgues are overwhelmed there are
warnings that official statistics may
not capture people who died suddenly at
home that does happen in other epidemics
especially when the disease is similar
to COBIT where people died quite
suddenly if they do have serious
complications from it New York's
governor sees faint signs of hope the
number of deaths was relatively steady
for a second straight day
hospitalizations have started to fall
but it's not clear what that means
there's also a real danger in getting
overconfident too quickly this is an
enemy that we have underestimated from
day one and we have paid the price
dearly and other cities are just now
seeing their numbers surge there are
15,000 cases in the state of Michigan
now the third highest number in the US
and there are fears of a public health
crisis in poorer rural areas those are
the scary questions we
or wrestling with right now it doesn't
it doesn't look promising for a lot of
areas particularly the us-south it does
not look promising it looks like we'll
have probably higher hospitalization
rates than were anticipated in hard-hit
New York they're preparing for every
possible scenario that could include the
short term burial of bodies in mass
graves in some city parks Donna
unbelievable Jackson prosecco in
Washington thinks ahead carmakers
adjusting production in an effort to
help with this pandemic this is a
prototype for a ventilator designed by
engineers at Tesla it's made from
redeployed car parts their Vice uses a
model 3 electric sedan touchscreen pumps
compressors and an oxygen mixing chamber
it hasn't been tested or approved Tesla
is just one of the many companies trying
to come up with innovative solutions
right now
Bill Gates says he will spend billions
to accelerate the development of a kovat
19 vaccine the Microsoft co-founder says
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
will have factories built for seven
potential vaccines he acknowledges a lot
of money is going to be wasted as it's
likely only two of those vaccines will
end up being effective but the financial
boost will accelerate the whole process
up next can you get Co bid 19 from
animals more answers to your coronavirus
questions
as we learn more about this virus the
response evolves - and your questions
about it keep coming Jeff simple has the
answers to some more of them tonight one
of the latest kovat 19 cases caught even
health experts by surprise
it surprised everyone because that
hadn't been documented before this tiger
at New York City's Bronx Zoo the first
animal in North America to test positive
leaving many cat owners curious about
the transmission between coronaviruses
have long lived in animals often
originating in bats several strains
including MERS and SARS have been made
the leap to humans and in a small number
of kovat 19 cases humans have been
infected felines and dogs but there
isn't clear evidence that the dogs for
example can transmit to humans
strangely none of the staff members at
the zoo has reported any symptoms
leading viewers to ask this I sling
tested nearly five percent of its
population regardless of whether they
had symptoms and nearly half of those
who tested positive were asymptomatic
then we've heard about transmission of
this infection in people that are going
to develop symptoms but haven't yet
developed symptoms yet it's unclear to
what extent that's happening in the
community that uncertainty prompted
Canada's top doctor to change course
advising people even without symptoms to
consider wearing non-medical homemade
masks hello my name is Kelly McCallum
and I live in marvel Alberta many of
these masks are designed with a pocket
to hold a filter in them and the
suggestions vary from using a coffee
filter to cutting up furnace filters and
vacuum bags number one I think if you
put those filters in place they might be
hard to free true on the other hand if I
use my my usual scarf my winter scarf
which is quite easy to breathe through
it probably isn't going to be terribly
effective so a lot depends
material here's how you can make your
own face covering in a few easy steps
Canadian and American public health
officials now recommend using 100%
cotton material like an old t-shirt with
elastic bands to create face coverings
but I always urge people to remember
that these are not a substitute for the
most important things which are washing
your hands not touching your mouth and
nose and in general staying out of
public just simple Global News Toronto
and we want to keep Jeff busy he's going
to continue to consult with experts and
try to answer your questions so send
them to your questions at global news
dossier and on our website you'll find a
special page dedicated entirely to CO
vid 19 that's at Global News CA /
coronavirus and that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna Friesen one of
the many things that's been cancelled
our citizenship ceremonies but last week
a special virtual citizenship ceremony
was held for adult Ning he is a
professor at the university of manitoba
canadian officials say his new
citizenship allows him to perform
essential work related to combating cope
in 19 and saving Canadian lives thanks
to him then thanks for watching
bye bye
you